hey everyone welcome to Abby's kitchen
today I want to talk a little bit about
some of the soul-searching I've been
doing as I've been reading and writing
and learning and like just fully
engrossing myself in the weight loss vs.
haze culture and argument honestly
there's like so much ground to cover so
I really wish I had a clone to help me
get through it but bear with me here so
I've been experiencing a lot of
professional growing pains for a few
months now and I've lost a lot of sleep
over it like I'm gonna do a whole other
video about my sleep situation at some
point but this week dr. Sharma who is a
obesity researcher here in Canada wrote
an article that not surprisingly
completely shook the registered
dietitian community so dr. Sharma in
this piece talked about how he felt that
registered dietitians were really
ill-equipped to help people who were
living with obesity because in his
experience a lot of our teas even fail
to acknowledge that obesity is a chronic
illness now I am NOT a big fan of this
guy's content in general especially
because he threw all the registered
dieticians under the bus despite the
fact that he works with a lot of amazing
are DS but it did really help me
acknowledge some of the feelings that
I've been grappling with as I move from
my own experience with disordered eating
and die culture to learning more about
haze and weight neutral practice so in
this Facebook group that I'm in for
registered dietitians there was a thread
about this piece and one of my amazing
colleagues Susan at McFarland whose
amazing she does a lot of plant-based
content as well if you're interested
talked about how she works with both
eating disorder patients and people who
are trying to lose weight which honestly
a lot of haze dietitians would see as
super problematic and and for that
reason I thought it was very interesting
in an unfortunate that she felt the need
she was very kind of scared to out
herself by coming forward in this thread
but what she said really struck me so
she said just because we don't believe
in
thin ideal should we be using our
clients or patients as martyrs for the
cause and the other thing she said which
I thought was very important and
interesting was that you know because a
lot of dietitians struggle with eating
disorders in their past we come from a
lot of disordered eating backgrounds
could we be projecting our own recovery
on our clients or patients and that
really hit me hard when I was thinking
about what she said because I never want
to do anything that doesn't help the
public I never want to be pushing my own
agenda at somebody else's expense but I
also realize that you know I'm coming at
this from my own experience you know my
damaging experience with diet culture
and I know that's a very common
experience like you guys are telling me
every single day in the comments section
how common this is but I also have to
realize that I may come off as
insensitive to some of you who may have
alternative experiences that I cannot
personally relate to and therefore it
might seem like I kind of gloss over
them now this article and the the
Facebook thread that I'm referring to
really sparked some amazing
conversations about the obesity
treatment versus the haze dietitian
world and you know those things really
got me feeling a bit lonely that I
didn't feel confident taking you know
one hard stance in this debate I know
I've said this in a previous video where
I mentioned that I don't identify myself
as a hazed dietician but rather that I
am kind of a hazed learner I know this
is controversial so I will just say this
I am a hey supporter and a hazed learner
I'm not a hazed expert that's still very
true in fact if in case you're wondering
a lot of haze dietitians don't like me
because they feel I'm too moderate in my
kind of stance when it comes to dieting
and weight loss like I haven't gone all
in so to speak so I've been operating in
this awkward gray space with you know a
true appreciation for the haze movement
and the philosophy and I've been letting
it inform my work
however having said all that I
think queer the disconnect lies for for
you guys is that I haven't been loud
enough about this gray space I haven't
been explicit enough about what it feels
like for me or even for you honestly I
think I've just gotten so caught up in
the social justice aspect and the
political correctness of the non-diet
movement and the fact that I just so
badly want society to change that I feel
like I've kind of lost touch with my
true purpose as a registered dietitian
and that is ultimately to help improve
individuals well-being and health both
physical and emotional health honestly I
am just one person so even though I so
badly want to I just feel ill equipped
to ultimately change society at large so
for a lot of people of course like
focusing on improving your health starts
with intuitive eating and accepting and
loving your body exactly as it is but
what about for those people who
weight-loss would improve their health
either physically or emotionally some
are these in the Hayes community would
say unequivocally that this is not a
thing that weight loss is not needed
that we need to just focus on body
acceptance now there are some more kind
of moderate Hayes dietitians that I've
liaised with who acknowledge that yes
like weight loss may help improve some
risk factors for disease and improve
health status however dieting we know
doesn't work so recommending dieting is
in a sense an irresponsible thing for us
to do as registered dieticians because
we know that it can actually be you know
kind of useless at best and really
dangerous at worse
to your physical and metabolic and
emotional health I believe that I've
seen so much of that and I talked about
that in my previous video here and
here's my professional research informed
opinion weight loss may improve certain
chronic health conditions there is a lot
of correlational research linking weight
loss and improved health outcomes and in
some cases I can't deny that it may play
a role the challenge with the
recommendation of course to just go lose
weight
is that the research suggests time and
time again that weight loss diets do not
work so some might say that going on in
intentional weight loss diet is a bit of
a risk and benefit analysis and that's
only something that you can decide
whether it's worth doing with your
practitioner and a registered dietician
but I still don't feel fully satisfied
that that is enough for some of you and
I'm not sure that it's enough for me
either
we know that diets don't work I mean the
research tells us that but does that
mean that we should stop looking for
solutions that do my heart says no so
what I really want to reiterate in this
quick little vlog video here is that I
truly believe in client centered care
I believe in body autonomy I believe
that you have a right to want to change
your body even if that means it
reinforces diet culture and even if I
don't think as a professional that it's
gonna have a measurable impact on your
health you have that right and I support
that right this like isn't a new belief
this is not something that I just came
up with right now this is something I've
talked about before however I do think
on you know further reflection that I've
been maybe unnecessarily critical of
youtubers who who promote weight loss or
promote fat loss and I've done that in
my effort to call out how insidious diet
culture really is but through a little
bit of reflection I think I've come to
terms with the idea that I think I need
to be a little bit more neutral in my
analysis in an effort to stop the shame
that people feel around wanting to lose
weight I have always said that it's
completely normal to want to lose weight
we live and breathe India culture that
is a totally normal thing to want and I
support a wide range of goals so you
know I've come to realize like Who am I
to say that you know wanting to lose
weight for health reasons is okay but
it's not for aesthetic reasons I just
realized that that is not fair for me to
decide and you know I could keep
hammering away at this despite feeling
this kind of icky disconnect but I think
part of being a
good strong professional means
continuing to learn and to gather
information and to apply those learnings
to your practice being Switzerland is
never sexy but I think what's most
important here is that we're
evidence-based and we're client centered
bottom line if you want to give up the
pursuit of weight loss I support you if
you want to continue to try to lose
weight I support you honestly I would
rather you get evidence-based
information from registered dietitians
like me than to go follow a dangerous
meal plan from a you know wellness
youtuber online so to close here folks I
want to just hammer home that if I have
ever lost sight of your needs or made
you feel unheard in your experiences or
your desire to lose weight I'm sorry I'm
truly truly deeply sorry I am going to
personally work to change that so that
abby's kitchen is a supportive space for
inspiring everyone's unique version of
health so tell me what it is that you
all need from me and I will do my
absolute best to make it happen so on
that note definitely leave me some
comments below give this video a like if
you like this message and if this is
helpful for you I hope that you're
feeling supportive I hope that you know
that I am with you on your journey of
course subscribe to the channel and I
will see you next time on Abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]
[Music]